[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I keep forgetting that it just drops in
like that
totally click right away that's alright
there's no play a banjo today I just
totally stole the intro from you and I'm
so sorry no it's all good I was too busy
grooving out music anyway it should is
that treasure trove Cove gym that you
can't not help but rock out to be yeah
the plan today indeed do classic mode
and then we're gonna take it online and
fight against you guys see what's going
on I've been this is Persia intros are
all sorts of messed up because I'm just
excited to play this gosh darn video
games yeah exactly it is all good we are
here happy Tuesday everybody yeah we all
know this already banjo kazooie is in
smash the freshest of the DLCs so we're
gonna run through some classic mode like
been said but if you guys want to pull
you online in a little while then you
better start up your switches and get
ready but yeah we were obviously talking
about how amazing the music was II just
don't get music like this anymore it's
true banjo I was actually telling you
while we were getting ready the like the
whole focus of the game is music the
main character's name is banjo like
notes so we get to start off the whole
theme for the classic mode is so
characters that have but for anybody in
chat who's already played some of the
banjo kazooie DLC what do you think of
the character I mean I know when banjo
first dropped like the tournament
results for already ham there's already
like half of a toffee all banjos sands
undertale because sands also dropped
almost stealing all the thunder from
damn jones off of that yeah it's wild
though that there Sony people now that
are playing a character
little DS Crash Bandicoot is in the chat
crash how about we have some crash 4
there's a lot of people will kind of
hold for him hey I'd be totally down
[Applause]
yeah the other thing too there's so many
like video games they've been coming out
and it passed like couple of weeks that
I've been having a very difficult time
concentrating on playing
I know it's true especially after banjo
came out and I've been finding myself
just playing banjo but that's where we
are really want the DLC Jim it's so good
yeah it's pretty awesome
I think they knocked it out of the park
with all the new stuff they added this
time around and you know those are
reveal trailers and stuff especially for
Terry Bogard
so good yeah so good it's really cool
how smash is like doing a very good job
of kind of like I don't know if respect
is the right word for they're just
you're doing really well it kind of
showcasing what's I agree they're doing
a good job at like capturing the essence
without them losing their smash you know
theme right like they still paid homage
to like final fight Terry Bogard all
update all that good stuff right yeah
but it was still very smashed like at
the same time and I like who's new
Rinda yes very nice very nice I wonder
how far along he is cuz he looks like at
least visually very very well done but
I'm excited for Terry this isn't an
actual view now they're just like okay
you guys are from the same place Fox and
Falco are pretty good friends though
Falco's kind of a maybe he should just
be on his back and then I would be more
where I appreciate it I've been really
good dang see Spyro and smash that'd be
really good to breezing through this so
there is no duo strong enough to defeat
Banjo and Kazooie it's the truth that
this Donkey Kong diddy kong combo is
pretty good yeah I believe and wasn't
gonna be an awesome character for like
team tournaments because he has a lot of
no forward and backwards coverage it's
also got outstanding Jojo energy wish is
something I really look for in all of my
characters that I play but uh I just
love how thoughtfully well the
characters put together every move is
something pulled from one of the games
all the sound effects I don't know if
anyone's confirmed it sound like they're
pulled right from the old games
variant and you're really here when they
announce them
I was not here oh yeah over at the base
yeah for me
anyone who lost it I maybe got a little
too excited no such thing you know
people always ask that question of like
who do you want smash and I used to try
to only think of you know who would
actually probably make it but now I'm
seeing some of the characters in here
the whole thing is possible I I'm
actually the weird point where like I
don't know who else I'd really want
outside of maybe like I mean I'm not
gonna like die of Travis touchdown
doesn't make it in but I'd like to see
him Kosmic here you put him in any
fighting game he deserves it yeah I'm
really happy that I got banjo the duo
here is Master Hand and crazy and yeah
it's like it's a embarrass myself a mess
myself what did you oh it's like which
ones which really the only way you can
tell them that you want over their Idol
and yeah like spirit fingers going on oh
my goodness you're literally catching
these hands look you got this you got
this that hand is dizzy Oh God
you guys don't know this but crazy hand
is actually sexual chocolate and may
Young's child
oh shoot look in the deep war I didn't
expect that you know they put everybody
in smash and you know they meant it
don't talk go knock me off you got this
yes you got one down
crazy hands the only one that's left
this is good this is that Oh
oh my goodness what in the world he was
breakdancing honey you know it's crazy
what what these hands can do what we got
so that's that's it good that's a good
warm-up you feel so we'll go through the
credits then we'll set up a lobby so
that people can jump in and show me how
to actually play the character no more
sword fighters banjos my favorite sword
fighter kazooie is just a sword
exactly see that beak oh sure I tried to
do this that it would be six point nine
and I messed up I can't believe it
so close yet so far I have a reman
Rayman would be really cool music again
yeah earthworm jim put him in here
as much as I want steer listen the sweet
grant kirkhope rearrangement online
Lobby used to fight in what up crime
welcome back
crying crying Bob James and Felix
legendary geek it's a me tree could
always pals hanging out I love it
alright so join up you guys join our
lobby you guys should also pick some
banjo does that see we're showing off to
this or if you feeling it's ins sands is
a popular carry join our arenas will
give you the code surely anything goes
public public yeah just do one D ones
cuz it's a lot easier and better for
connections let's speak a rule set that
we'll do five minutes at the most and
we'll do like to stock we want to have a
little bit of time to play but we don't
want to like you don't want to take too
much keep a bottom on that's yeah winner
stays wait I should probably do it sure
do a password not let's not do a
password yeah we're good we'll just call
it game spot and make it easy to find
don't pick the same color a banjo you're
right crime it's true alright guys there
you go shirts one one one one
yeah it's a lot of ones for once join us
create that arena
[Music]
let's change our music here and then
because we got it we got to do it at
some point
Brandon says here's fiver ice-born for
Community Friday this week I think you
guys already played both of those oh we
haven't done gears 5 and I think that
multiplayer yeah yeah so if you need it
you can actually I think just join what
the ID and then the password is up there
underneath it so come on in yeah
join us that do banjo color it's it's do
or it's boggy one of the two I'm just
really glad that they got boggy in there
somehow
so made me think at conquer - I was kind
of hoping we'd maybe get some like
conquer music maybe get some more just
rare stuff but I'm still pretty good so
you gotta do that under tailor paid that
extra money not for that costume but
just for the song where that's what I'm
here for the music makes it worth it
dropping and I'm gonna leave this up
just a little bit longer yes join us i
BCM 18w we got Oni John and Buddha yeah
I'm uh I'm ready to get works Oh
shouldn't you change my character oh
yeah I need to change it - banjo I'm not
I'm not a snake mean anything banjo man
we're banjo means now and it's ticket oh
yeah and banjos stage of course gobies
Valley a sleeper hit song new reason
you'll see James Bond James Bond for
smash - I'm down I'll be awesome
apparently they were considering it at
one point oh I got the grunty color
let's go banjo mirrors ready show show
me what cool tech you've got uh a Chan
let's do it
I'm ready Oni he kind of blends in with
stage a little thugs attack precision
very smart
so some let's see I have the move set
here for Banjo and Kazooie in which if
you guys didn't see the character break
I didn't I didn't plan on either but
we've got I overhear there we go yeah
throw it out of here that's that's the
other pod not gonna pick that up
oh no brands you know I love the grenade
because both players can like throw it
around which is pretty cool
okay cuz I even though I'm not playing
snake anymore I I don't have to worry
about giving up my grenade it's still
there exactly that move is so good goes
so far
and we got a smash ball in play
oh Allah make Smash Ball and play I
probably should change the ruleset I
like how we're both respecting each
other enough to go for it you know what
you've got it if you see an opportunity
just do it because I want to see the
finals yes cuz this is a way to show off
all the parts of the character mater
it's here
oh I'm gonna make it
no bad job he didn't make it actually
does have some really awesome aerial
moves to help him get back on platform
but sometimes meta I can get get that
going Oh No
[Music]
so we're all still kind of trying to
work it out a bit here and that's that's
what's good a lot of utility though
which is good I do
I do love banjos recovery more than most
times and it makes sense that I'm glad
that you took that in one of the risk
flying off it what's your take on who's
gonna be invited next to smash yeah I
mean we briefly talks about it but
there's no limits now Oh anyway I'm so
sorry no Isaac get out of here Oh Olli
uh oh my goodness everyone
you can't fight against Isaac because
all he does is just push you on
that's dumb I'm sorry I don't think I
can
Jeeter change the rules yes make a whole
new pack out and redo it pink player
lists arena settings I don't think it
just shows the card for it it will do
this match and then I'll back out after
it yeah
we'll make a new lab eating no items we
want to see banjo and all of his glory
here captain toad and smash would be
good but he can't he can't jump problem
I appreciate that we're on a sonic level
is on Acuras plan because what goes up
must come down never played sonic heroes
in my life but I know the songs GG's
Felix because items are OPA they are
great I'll get this out here there we go
[Music]
it only wouldn't benefit was City escape
only that's that's just me Mike Tyson
the punch-out version yeah that would be
agree no don't pick up that leg Gump are
linked from breath of the wild that's a
good call
I got some good news for you Sean we've
got more links than you can shake a
stick at in this video game crime once
any as ninja cat in smash I don't know
if I know that one but I trust crime
right exactly that's that's good alright
let's go turn off good fight
TV's tails and Eggman and smash just
bring everyone everyone who is already
in here other people from their games
should be in here too yeah
all of them any time now some
megalovania is still just a plus yes
okay guys rear we are releasing it do it
right this time
[Music]
this items its GameSpot again let's do
the same things and one one one crate
arena now this is for real is it been a
finally met his match
hey yeah I'll I'll be the first to admit
I'm not like the best at smashed but I
can hold my own for the most part
what's our IP oh yeah that's right I did
I prioritize the music beforehand to hg3
seven small girls on switch we're still
waiting I know
waiting forever I'm excited for it
though it is near I know it and I know
it's gonna run great because I feel like
that's a type of game just totally built
for something like switch yeah I'll
leave this up until we start seeing a
couple people get in
we'll go off that way and just kind of
groove out while we wait this game
soundtrack maybe my second favorite part
about unlocking things is how many songs
there are cuz after I got all the
characters I was like oh no now what do
I do realize that there are like four
hundred songs in the game to find and I
think I actually got all well some
pretty pretty stoked about that infinite
to Ninja Turtles would be good Ryu
Hayabusa would be great
alright god we got people coming over
even smash ready to smash we got a hero
oh snap love it I thought it was
hilarious that people in the smash
community were like really debating
about banning hero
yeah the random elements are our thing
but I think that's kind of what makes it
fun right I mean RNG is not always gonna
be in their favor just how it works but
when it is glorious another good thing
too about this is if I lose I start to
watch other people play as long as some
of you pick banjo we're good
yo I'm telling or undertale like it gets
sands on the tail going yeah saw that
that menu pop up
and now he's trying we that was wild
it's okay God we got we got a good
almost trade even though they're
cheering for me even though I got God
here for you regardless I guess oh that
was scary
yike Rooney's yeah look at that spacing
impeccable we blocked those Hey look
we're fighting underwater a little yeah
we're chugging along quite a bit we're
we're making it work though oh no he's
got ohms to block that time
I have no more feathers left what do I
do
can't fly without feather for injury
some of these moves are just so tough on
him oh man oh man let's go it's a close
one
oh we've got a range I'm so nervous
right Oh
oh my god let's go Finn oh let's go Finn
be one with the water you got time it
you've got oh he's close
oh that was dangerous
sonica go for oh my gosh is the life
it's so close Dana
oh gosh I was it don't get me don't
don't like me or I swear not in front of
bottles I can't let him down like this
just taught me all these moves yeah I
stopped breathing for the last 30
seconds that fight that was too much my
heart can't take this this early in the
morning that was really close
it's a good fight I like the good game
whoo so it's Casper the point is to
damage your opponent and then the more
damage they take the further they get
knocked off the platform right and then
eventually they won't be able to make it
back or does this get blown away so
that's that's pretty much the point of
the percentage game so sometimes I'll
you know especially when I was first
watching smash I was like men they've
already taken so much there has to be it
and then they still somehow bring it all
the way back so it's not necessarily you
know the deciding factor but it's
definitely a part of the plan yeah
oh snap the frame has renamed banjo -
Benjo uh my I think my twitter name is
still Ben Jenkins ooey right now on
Twitter and I'm very into that heck yeah
is Michael that gave it to me Antonio
does a call out to banjos line when you
pick him in
Diddy Kong Racing and that's the only
thing that is missing I wish were here
because when you when you pick him in
the game he goes
I'm fine Joe it's my favorite bit the
bin Joe mirrors ooh that was a perfectly
time for knee there Ben
I do love these grenades oh you can
throw it straight up and in oh yeah I
have to catch it yeah that stuff's gonna
do some cool yeah well tuck you got a
dude let's stuff this fun oh oh what are
the feathers give you so it's Heidi
you're wondering which in the game made
banjo invincible for however long you
had the feathers for so you want to get
five and basically makes you invincible
you do damage and that's kind of it and
it moves you forward
it's Pokemon stages I know never get
over it
so yeah I'm definitely thinking I want
to see some Wolverine and smash
something about his moveset right like
he uses like DP pretty much yeah his
tornado claw and stuff to get up for it
it's got divekick obviously he doesn't
like a dyke it's true he's also got that
if it is an Ultimate Marvel 3 they gave
him that Swiss cheese yeah I mean I get
to hear Wolverine like grunt through his
teeth that's worth a so great I don't
shoot eggs nearly enough which is is a
thing
[Music]
the blocks or the dodge scoops it kind
of sucks it like banjos only good
throwers is back one I found so far dang
but now you're on a to win streak super
mandible nose Travis touchdown for smash
definitely oh snap
though it was a good fight it's a good
fight until until though yeah Gigi's
Felix onii-chan up next we got oh this
is it Oh feel sans coming oh we're gonna
have a real bad time I'm ready for it
like how the faces I don't know how to
apply to me your honor because no one
ever picks we've done it and on final
destination oh dang and deep down in the
deep blue sea here we are
oh boy good look at all those cool banjo
these expressions though this is
actually instant replay
oh boy I love how you can tell that he
was doing like a punch but it just
completely lifts although I am glad I've
got to see the sense in these same there
we go
it's really great that that that wonder
wing move is just like an anti
projectile thing because my my roommate
loves playing just projectile characters
so it's like the perfect anti everything
he does Jesse says Banjos throw is back
and down on down you can go into side
beam you have on the side but you can do
up smash - which noise but they changed
how how burying people works and it's
made me like use it a lot less flipping
when the game first came out we can't
rule had that oh god this is this is
intense lag here working it we're doing
it okay definitely work and everything's
everything's gonna work out this is
gonna be fine
it is what it is you know online can't
be perfect all the time
it's true it takes two to tango you guys
just walk into that fire really quick oh
my lord oh no the struggle continues its
work this is fine everything's fine
everything it's not enough though and a
lot of others it's okay oh no that was
close just a little off come on banjo
you got this fire yeah whoo oh yeah oh
yeah oh I love it was it was a good
fight for all the frames of it I feel
like we both probably would have done a
lot better have the connection been
better but I still had a good time
thank you for bringing the sands yes
thank you thank you
you know the lag helped us appreciate
the costume more yeah sure I'm gonna I'm
gonna change my my level really quick
and also it'll give
Raja's fight yes so I was worried that
it's just gonna go into the banjos level
with Toby's valley again that's not bad
we're here to feature some good old
banjo don't spiral Mountain perfect yeah
[Music]
let's get that lets get the run back
yeah you guys had an onsen fighting
laughter ah me and again if you guys
want to join we do let me go back and
get that info we're just hanging out
playing banjo playing sands plain
gyro played smash I know all the new
stuff miss use my strongest move to take
some damage there
now singing about some other characters
I would like but then I realized in
their respective fighting in most of
them have a flight mode which seems like
it would be super cheap in this I will
never fall off the map
I have played banjo at a better a
jetpack earlier wasn't that okay so you
know naturally I was like Magneto
let's buy my own hair Sam Morgan there
you go how they wait that might be kinda
cheap I think Morgan would be a fun
character though I want to see smash
players struggle it's wild how Morgan
like a lot of people know who Morgan is
even though she hasn't been right
exactly
I feel like I've been hearing the the
call and once for another Darkstalkers
for quite some time now yeah but only
from like the core group George still
invested if you're really cool to see
you come back I think if it did it would
be popular to be honest I feel like a
lot of those older fighting in would
totally you know beep well receptive so
you're smart too my am i rolling in yeah
he's not having it which I need to not
do so much oh there it is it's a good
fight Jesse M says who is the superior
DLC character
I mean I guess hero right now because in
tournaments like seen a lot of people
actually think he's ope but like the
first week banjo is out this week or
whatever it's like the tournament
results showed that a lot of people were
placing all the banjo already sound it's
too soon
no personal bias banjo first you like to
see the world burn apparently yes I want
you all to struggle as I did in Marvel
for many years feel our pain switch this
up
Dante from Devil May Cry a lot of people
want Dantas yeah well I remember a
playstation allstars right he was in
that which was kind of like the
PlayStation version well they fight I'm
gonna put this up here so you guys can
join yes then if you want to join this
is our ID and that's our password drug
room in here Sora from Kingdom Hearts
he'd be a great fit why are we not at
apples I don't do journalism's so I just
get to hang out and play video games so
I'm doing what I got it's it's happening
they showed us sign our wild hearts some
gameplay the game looks really good saw
it before we came in here more f-zero
character is very good call that
beautiful Joe would be so good oh yeah
now that they have this like your name
and can equip banjo I can definitely see
a beautiful Joe in here yeah doing the
same old thing cuz that was actually one
of my most favorite things about
beautiful Joe and Marvel 3 like he had
the bomb which is really awesome but you
know both players could hit it back and
forth it did damage to both players too
so you kind of to be careful yeah it
added for a lot of fun I know maybe the
last remaining like most requested
character is probably Geno and I feel
like Geno has to me
they've been doing a very good job of
listening to people for all the DLC for
this it seems like sweet the the fact
that we have sans with like the
exception of a song is probably the
biggest evidence of them being like oh
yeah we see everyone asking for a thing
yeah they're listening so I feel like
Geno's probably like a good bet for not
if not the last character for this one
definitely the next one so many euros
already did give us a zero outfit super
mandible claw says are you going to
stream the Modern Warfare beta you know
it I am just counting down the second
Thursday that is when we are planning to
stream in the beta unless we get lucky
and they drop it earlier something like
they did with the Alpha yeah right
which low-key were all praying for that
but if not the ps4 early access of the
beta starts Thursday yeah III think that
crime put about Leon Kennedy you like if
there were any resident evil character
that had a chance to make it in Leon's
probably it specifically from resi
before just because he's been on three
Nintendo consoles which he's been in
more games than cloud has on a Nintendo
console so although as a Wesker player I
would say what's gonna be freaking dope
in this what's girls pretty cool Scout
like the Team Fortress Scout oh I'm
guessing Team Fortress Scout because
you've got an engineer as your profile
picture soundboard they'd be pretty fun
let's see I mean yeah I would rather
have Puss in Boots
yeah there you go missing boots he would
have a move set like a picture yeah
Skull Kid would be really cool I feel
like school kids got to happen at some
point
Goku don't know about that just be
but Shrek yeah yes Shrek in there Shrek
might have been in more games on a
Nintendo console than cloud has it's cuz
it's Shrek yeah
what can you think I'm just there's a
part of me that's really upset the
clouds in smash I not so like put anyone
down who loves Final Fantasy 7 or
anything I just never I missed the boat
on it and I'm just sad ooh a Tekken
character would be cool and smashed heck
yeah I'll get that home run for a final
smash I'm in the possibilities are
endless
alright listen now I feel like I might
have been put up on the stand and missed
my chance to go in but I think we're
good now yeah I think you're next
cuphead no be cool
we're playing Shrek - that's a good
question
we almost did it when we were playing
Mortal Kombat wins the Shrek open-world
adventure game coming where we can go to
every every place and striking a brick
wall it's gonna say what's happening
here they're like oh I won the last
fight against you on that counter stroke
Cove is maybe the top of steer banjo
song I love it so much no come back here
[Music]
mandible claw so dedicated servers win
you think that with the amount were
paying for for online they'd have
something great honestly too late with
this game they're clearly working on it
in a way that they want people to play
it they're adding all these fan favorite
characters and all of that so I would
say you know a dedicated great people
want to bring characters but if it's
super laggy some people will be Landin
however us so I'm the other hand we
enjoy this masochism yeah it makes us
stronger and by the time we actually
fight a match that doesn't have leg we
forget how to actually play
who I'm really upset that that move
doesn't stop
I got crit and that's okay it happens
happening you can't use a land capable
you got to get the little dongle that's
what we use we have a little dongle
that's us we connected and when you plug
into the the dog and then the yeah the
ethernet cord goes into philosophy so I
would highly recommend getting one of
those if you guys want to play we'll
just sit in there Oh
scorpion from m'kay scorpion getting
everyone a snap
sans was released early he's uh he's not
I guess he came out with the update but
it's it's not like sands as sands it
stands as a meat on earth oh yeah I
really do enjoy playing banjo makes me
really happy
oh you're out if you fart I see you
Garfield before while he's gone oh
what's going on Sakurai and uh and
waluigi put you got this gold falcon
here Oh Sam I really love captain falcon
in this game a lot captain talking in
Smash in general I miss f-zero
when are we getting f-zero back Falcon
kick my actual my phone like
notification sound for text is Captain
Falcon saying yes and it never gets old
I've had it that was like three years
and I can't change it Marcus from Gears
oh snap that'd be pretty interesting to
see I don't know how they make it work
but I just want to see him chainsaw
someone still one of my favorite things
well as I'm vulgar is Raptor boosting so
fast Captain Falcon you're so fast oh I
think you're gonna like stop him on your
platform very cool so it does hit when
you when you drop it on them
oh yeah some of those up aerials in
there oh oh I got a let's get one throw
them off the stage
oh my god Nate yeah let's go let's go
dear golden feathers refill overtime
it's like once per stock right good five
per stock and you have to die to get
more so use them wisely come on here we
go
yeah fighting back let's get this
comeback bin all the deflect online
like a banjo just steaming now it's like
an old car he's like alright I'm getting
beat up I was like talking kicks got him
coming soon in front of mumbo - I can't
believe it's a good fight if fans why
the leaves anyone it had to be gold felt
those muscles that torso oh it's a
beautiful man all right let's see what
see what other people have got yeah give
everyone a chance to fight each other a
bit although sir Pikachu definitely had
some connection issues last time see if
it gets a little better I think one more
spectating it doesn't really show it's
possible might be like rolled back we're
on a plan oh snap
see piranha plant was definitely a
character where I was like I don't see
how you know they can create a mood set
for him and they totally did and they're
actually really fun to play oh man this
this connect still still fighting a
little bit underwater that's fine
whoa no now he was like no I refuse to
do this to myself oh no refuse I respect
that an easy win that's that's the
ultimate strategy
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah you know we love you Pikachu we do
but uh ya seen feelings like sorry can't
do lag it's understandable yes can't I
mean a certain to a certain extent we
can deal with it oh you know what
Pikachu thank you bro
thank you we appreciate the the
sacrifice it was good plenty of the the
one fight that we did though yes it
wasn't too bad buddy it was a thing all
right back at it
so at this point we've played each other
enough that we've got like each other
downloaded we know who's gonna be one
step ahead
Mandeville says it's never lag like this
this bad before maybe you know we've
just found a lot of fresh new content
man there's a lot of people I don't know
but it could be something to do with our
office connection do because there's
some weird like that stuff we have to do
eh
I saw that menu come up and I wasn't
anywhere near being able to interrupt he
made it so I really liked this version
of a spiral mountain theme because it
does a good job representing the entire
like banjo game Oh God and that it it
has a little bit of every stages theme
in it like dirty like a breakdown which
is really great
oh no the other side it's behind also I
kind of wish that spiral mountains
gimmick wasn't look I get what they're
doing but it'd be cool if there's an
option to like turn it off I don't know
if it counts as like a stage hazard
I actually feel like unless I just
wasn't paying attention but I haven't
seen it spinning yet if I saw in other
parts of this stage when it spins more
platforms pop up and stuff of them so no
I think this is the trick so I think
this is the final destination version of
save dang you got my number but imma get
the run back as soon as we get through
everyone else yeah coming back yeah
[Applause]
if you guys want to see all the info on
banjo the smash wiki axe has all the
moves how much damage they do the
properties that they have oh we do have
an arena if you want to join yeah that's
that's where we are I can't show you the
info but it's there in the chat if you
want it that's the ID in the past spam
it for you again if you want play he's
joined God we got banjo on Zack we've
got hero on deck god golden Falcon
having a good time and if you're worried
about being not good enough or you're
worried about being too good everyone's
welcome come on in
just show us how good or bad you are
guarantee you'll have a good time you
I I can't wrap my mind around here oh I
kind of like the one thing that keeps me
from ela play him is that his spell Asst
pops up down and if it popped up like on
him or close to him like where I was
actually looking great I'm probably have
an easier time playing I'm getting this
camera get my check do the thing sound
bored it's so good I think it might be
[Music]
but for game that came out last year I'm
still playing it a lot like yeah and
there's still like so much new stuff DLC
content that was brutal I can't believe
we just witnessed to learn alive oh my
god another murder yeah yeah yeah and if
you do get the game sound board
definitely join us for when we play
smash impending physics to get one of
the games we like to bring back on where
that is right it's going to promo I'm
really excited yeah we're on one of our
shows that we do every weekday at 11
a.m. Pacific Friday John Luke and I play
games with you guys in the community I
know it's Tuesday and we're playing at
the anyway but that's fine but Friday
the the live show is dedicated straight
up to just hanging out
this week I believe were playing yes we
did Master Hunter last week so we'll do
like some versus multiplayer with you
guys or maybe support made whatever
works good time
now it's spinning the whole channel [ __ ]
internet access which note yeah I wish
there's a look at I don't want to say
like a mole like a mobile data service
or something for the stretch but
something like what sure now that would
be in my opinion the next step for
handheld device devices that can somehow
I mean of course you would have to pay
him on CD it could they make a monthly
subscription that included like
obviously your your game function like
normal but also include like a hotspot
or Wi-Fi or something I think that would
be cool yes I don't know who they do it
troops I remember when was the the Vida
came out in there like we've got a deal
with AT&T and there are people who are
like yeah that's yeah I think I've
always thought you know all these
Internet companies are talking about how
they have the best coverage or the
bestest best that and they show you the
math and everything oh your your Falcon
is on now holy cow this is like night
and day from the last time I fought you
you're you're feeling it he's in the
groove I love it
so chat let me ask you guys a question
let's say the switch had an internet
service with its monthly subscription
all right what's the Nintendo
subscription column personal online or
something - no online okay so if
Nintendo online I think it's like four
dollars a month right now but if it went
up to like it would have to be somewhere
around like 25 to 30 dollars a month if
you're paying for the Internet is so
wherever you go and the online
membership and then it could probably
have some third functionality of like
being its own hotspot for your mobile or
something up - how much would you pay
per month for a subscription like that
these are these are really good matches
for Bursar's just been playing smash a
whole bunch follow me over like play
with people is yeah especially with the
homie banjo yeah but yeah I feel like I
would definitely pay for something like
that 25 a month if you could serve serve
all those things like you could go any
way you want play online whenever don't
worry about hooking up to a connection
hotspot or Ethernet cable or whatever
believe it yeah I think the streaming
apps like Netflix and Hulu all that that
would already be be a part of the deal I
feel like that would be like it was a
good fight I mean I'm sorry about that
I know GG's Felix oh my god we got
people in here I love it yeah see that
that Wario hanging out
[Music]
cuz like I think about my cell phone
service right now I play like I feel
like I don't know like 45 a month from
my cell phone service so any no I only
pay that much because I want the
unlimited data I don't really care about
minutes and texts as much I feel like
all these anyways so I guess that's why
I'm willing to pay a little bit more
than like ten dollars a month for a
subscription like that but it's cuz are
supposed to be friends now Oh
apparently not that's right I'm ready to
get I was getting ready for the dunk it
was coming so that the one thing I'm
looking i played enough DK to know the
one good thing about banjo is he's gonna
be able to use that third jump to go a
little bit higher than most DJ's are
used together to avoid getting dunked
hopefully and I say that and I'm gonna
get dunked literally the next chance
happens
[Music]
yeah I would
everything a subscription like that
would be for the people who most of
things that they do play has some sort
of online functions ooh that was a nice
combo no no no I wasn't ready for to
hold out I still wasn't ready I wasn't
prepared at all he thought he was like
oh you think DK stands for Donkey Kong
it's actually Donkey Kong that's all he
does everyday was a good fight I love it
good stuff this is good though cuz now I
get to sit back yeah
ooh we're gonna see some DK vs. hero
action necks like ours are you talking
DK impeccable yes everything I'm knocks
it five the right taunts the right dunks
the right setups
ooh oh now we good sometimes you dump a
little too hard oh man
Donkey Kong is serious Oh dominated
cartoon that's real good we're all the
DS are flipping oh man he's so big -
he's just like I'm gonna use my body and
stop you Marthe gaming says I love for
China whoa thank you we love you man
wouldn't be doing it if it weren't for
you guys oh he's got the menu up all he
was trying but Donkey conscious all over
him he's down about I say kind of kind
of level but I understand I popped off a
little bit Oh with you about the just
sacrifice both of them throw him and
jump off it was close so you do like
that nice you bounce them off of it in
the Ricochet the right way
okay that's messed up but Tony where I
think it was up the stock just grab him
we're both going down toxic toxic got it
on lock yeah that was great
all right we got fat boy next you are
toxic I'm really good making those
strategic plays totally like see mr.
human watch oh snap this is another
character along with like duck hunt that
really made me think man anyone mr. game
watch was the prototype for Hiro
original mr. orangey see if we get any
nines on this this dice roll to see if
it happens so create Turtles full effect
right now ooh
it's lit the cooking them serving up the
sausage at home
oh man as he fell down
whoa oh don't let it happen again
yeah Romans talking about what I was
getting that is if you if you do the
throat just right against the bottom
over Cochet down yeah
[Music]
oh I know crime I know we all miss Eric
he's a busy man though it's a busy man
with lots of responsibilities which is
why we don't get to see him as much Oh
made it clap yeah clap them in the back
dog calling top to you talk that
downside staring at the screen breaking
the fourth imagine a four month process
was online co-op stuff gets pretty nuts
for that I'm not very good at it foot
watching other people do it so it's a
heck of a thing
it's Arndt's kind of bad no offense
Sonic's alright he's not my kind of
thing though his stages and music though
point
ooh this can be a good match because
both of these guys have been kind of
show it off see definitely putting on
there
I believe our goal Falcon can do it
they're thinking caps here holding on
strangers a good fight either way or a
short
oh so good it's so good it's so funny
too because then he gets the like the
ledge guard afterwards was even better
oh my god double joe toxic the double
Doug toxic box is not holding you back
at all right now this is this is what
Donkey Kong deserves though after being
such a low tier character and every
single smash leading up to this like how
Captain Falcon was clapping he had that
look on his face like every time it
comes back it's megalovania it's perfect
alright the next opponent stepping into
the ring young link true in crime just
posted up in Reno if you want to join in
it's not the devil dunk dude toxic Fox
has been Dunkin everybody so far it's
been quite the site
[Music]
some some professional young link play I
love it but to fish the Perry
[Music]
so this is what I'm here for I was
really hoping that we get some like
really good people and so I can just
like wash and uh some good smash I mean
it's not on the banjo level it's not
with banjo and it's not watching the mom
will like poop in there alone
yeah Pitt never learned how to read
that's the canonical fact the one thing
they regret feels bad you know if you
really think about it I don't ever
remember oh but it's against them this
side a risky maneuver but I respect it I
got I got works by Donkey Kong last time
and now if young link wind I love to
fight
sure Brandon there are so many good
games and I still need to see finish
fire emblem still need uh working on
control it is such an insane time to be
a game area now to be honest since like
this month is all these awesome games
coming out and then there's also all
these tournaments yeah
and events it's you saying there's no
like downtime anymore I feel like
additions for additional flavors we
talked about that a little bit earlier
but I think Travis touchdown in cosmic
unity I feel like they have an all right
dang that was good yeah it was a real
good fight someone finally stopped
toxics win streak now I'm afraid of the
small child oh man did you see I mean I
don't know if it was fact check but it's
all these articles about like people
dying to e-cigarettes know and they're
like trying to warn people to stop doing
it I was like oh dang it was Gary I have
no idea how any of that works be careful
before you vape guys it might be
dangerous all right let's do this
all right back up to bat I'm ready for
this match to last less than a less than
maybe a minute ding toxic Donkey Kong is
not even your man Shh ready to see your
main I know right see where that goes my
theme is that I want to switch so bad
same I don't have one yet which is so
sad oh I'm pretty new it
Oh professor layton or phoenix or iron
both of those would be fantastic
I don't know how Professor Layton would
play I don't know what his moveset would
be like it would just be fantastic they
have to throw in like the you are right
danced a little like reposes somehow
definitely my like one of my husband
Kelly you both spin the rim
all the deflecting then this sent me
flying can't believe it for kazooie then
moods are so brutal on him that's the
funny thing about that move is
canonically she's very into it which
they make a very big point of letting
you know also I think it was a move from
- I just get like Hulk and Loki vibes
like slamming Loki on the ground yeah
yeah there's a good fight lasted a bit
longer than I expected I don't know if
you're going a little bit easier on me
boys do you let's see who's up next
copycat it is your time look at how
adorable kirby is so cute but so Dean is
I love that meme where it's like win
short people are angry and it's like
Kirby with a knife yeah yeah it's Kirby
when they they absorb banjo actually
give and get a plush kazooie that they
shoot like a oh it's really adorable man
I want to see that now very very good
yeah fire arrows on water right Mars
type of crazy technology is this this is
a good version of warming erase but I
still think I like the other ones a bit
more this one's super dramatic but they
kind of match
[Applause]
[Music]
no one's kinda stupid since he has no
anyone yeah I hear a lot about how how
good young link is I really rarely see
people you know using him only Miss
Mississippi is a big deal in the game
first came out hey I'm still a big fan
of like just picking characters that you
like real Pokemon masters win with the
Pokemon they love what I tell myself
every time I lose because honestly it
makes playing more fun when you don't
even actually enjoy the character yeah I
I still remember like the first couple
of matches I played a banjo when I was
just learning like how to do stuff with
them against like a level 9 CPU and I
get like knocked off the stage it was
like I just smiled
[Music]
who is really cool like Kirby a lot this
green color rooster guy you got the Sun
lot on a roll I'm excited to see what
happens when toxic comes back around
with their their main yeah we got Daniel
in here min and Daniels one who said
Professor Layton so shoutouts to you for
that
I think that's do I feel like Professor
Lee was really awesome because they had
really cool like animated scenes not
really a cartoon they were so good I
haven't really gotten a chance to play
much of Professor Layton but my roommate
loves it and he tells me about it all
the time they're all amazing the puzzles
are you know that you're really hard
part of me is like how do they expect
like kids to play this because even some
of them I'm like nothing the actual for
real spiral mountains oh we've got that
and we're spiral bit yeah this keep away
though is working out
oh we spin and spin and win
we've got our our standout rehoming it
was a lot of Jojo going on right oh oh
oh oh man can he not you can't get back
up when that bridge came down huh maybe
I never thought about it being like a
thing he couldn't
I wasn't sure if you could still grab
the ledge or not dirty
yeah he went down and then the bridge
popped up right over him bottles just
having a good time know who these two
people are but oh but Joker also a
fairly recent character yeah putting up
very good fight against through stock
here as likely but I wish our would
right here so quell I'll still never
forget that twitch clip of hi I'm like
getting super hype at Evo oh yeah I'm
like showing off his jacket I didn't
expect him to be lucky right at the
front of like the final like as the
camera was going down the thing was a
good fight - oh thanks for liking and
subscribing my nanny says I'm his
favorite sorry babe
no way someone's gotta be first
someone's gotta be safe and you know
what you can't be first all time if I
can accept that then anybody else
watching you should also like and
subscribe you should also hit that
little bell to get notifications on when
we do things here on our channel which
is very important i you know back in the
day you didn't have to go that extra
step to like find out what was new and I
actually found out recently that a lot
of the youtubers I like to watch I
wasn't you know I didn't have the Bell
hit for them and I miss like months
worth of video so although it was nice
to go back and be like oh snap
because some more stuff to watch
everyone hide geez they're onto us
they saw our killer moves here they're
probably here for that murder that
happened earlier in the stream so Daniel
was like man I want to play with you
guys and now he's here he's killing it
he is I'm glad that we brought it back
for the banjo stage though yeah and we
get to see the platforms and all that
jazz
roars my favorite fire boys pretty cool
I think I'm not a big fireman guy but I
like I like I like his kind of like
weird asymmetrical design and he's got
what the really big finish today
Oh crime says sometimes need to click
the bell a few times
whoa make sense
whoa that was cool we definitely kept it
together though base on that ricochet
that was potentially dangerous if you
weren't ready for it I got those Donkey
Kong donkey vibes off of that who do we
want to guess what toxics you main
characters because we saw him go in hand
with some DK earlier but then after he
lost to young link he was like all right
my name it's time for the maze for next
we have limited time to guess hmm Ryu
he's Ryu main Oh whenever I think of
someone who plays this game and he knows
what they're talking about I think they
play fireman characters
oh not next there they're a couple away
so got timing okay yeah we have time we
applied no to your lists sure you're
talking about the to your list yeah yeah
exactly
yeah I need to see you Missy I'm gonna
say I'm gonna say look at it like a
classic like a Martha you've seen up
maybe a crime but if not a fireman
character I don't think you play like
Peter Daisy oh my God look away for a
second that was wild
oh if it's Lucas I swear let's get PK
frozen all the time my favorite
character in smash is Yoshi Yoshi is
just my favorite all right have your
character thing so maybe maybe Bowser
you're playing deep
everyone's favorite Pokemon Diddy Kong
all right it has to be like another
another another DK character pokemon
trainers also want to see a lot of but
here this is the truth this is the truth
moment who is it who can it be dope
that will Mac are you a test I'm ready
I'm ready to watch this I'm ready to see
I'm ready to see where it goes
actually I should have guessed that it
was messed because he kept having the
stage yeah I know like yo she's not the
best character but nothing gives me more
hype than watching AMSA in the older
ones at least I don't know if I've seen
him play this one actually let me throw
in something together here real soon in
four games to join we're still working
on it maybe possibly I don't know if you
were asking us or you were asking me
toxic in now
it would be cool to have a discord
actually there's there's a lot of like
logistical stuff that we need to setup
first Oh nonchalant so funny yeah like
this box there was all ripped and cut it
and then adorable little boy yeah well
the other thing too is the girl Mac is
just about as big as NASA yeah but also
messes got a baseball bat oh my goodness
that's what I'm saying
young yoshi is good yoshi the best in my
mind yo she's top terry is invincible on
every move with so many characters it's
kind of cool to be able to play this you
guys don't want to hate discord with me
I'm just gonna spin like spongebob memes
and talk about Marvel all day well you
know there's got to be a music oh man
your place to throw all that stuff that
was a good fight though yes I'm ready to
just get worked let's let's do it I'm
gonna I'm gonna be banjo at least though
so yeah that'll be good all right
I'm ready for it we went a little smile
Ness has psychopaths I've seen what that
kid does I've seen things they could do
he's actually on one of the episodes of
what's that serial killer show on
Netflix he's actually got an interview
mess about
all of his stuff is done he's murdered
almost every character in the roster but
he believes he's innocent
yeah once we and I'll get to discredit
up we'll definitely share it with you
guys but be patient with us it's a work
in progress
Huah neighs I appreciate that you like
you definitely not not going in on me
too much
hey maybe is cautious
[Music]
oh yeah that shouldn't happen but it did
we take those Ben give me away from
there
[Music]
oh how jump off your head there but Kira
says what's your opinion on JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure Survey enemy it's good
for us it's really great actually
you got another person in the office to
start watching it nice
[Music]
good fight though you messes geez
I could tell that you know what you'd do
any know where you're going and it was
Eva LG says Ben you roll too much do I
think that's because I was panicking
because I saw them in the last match
yeah but so then you should check out
this wiki it's got all the moves true
all the moves are right there some of
these you know sometimes when you read
the description for a move it sounds a
lot better than it actually is but some
of these sound really good Pikachu
party hat Pikachu coming in casting some
some sweet did we find the strat
this is it top tier strats and this was
like a Pikachu okay Oh an hour game
combo like that was cute but uh for real
though say no I know blocked him those
rules got diminishing returns
what sometimes thank you gotta believe I
also not even likewhat the diminishing
returns I tend to just roll as soon as
someone comes up to me to attack me
which means they get the attack anyway
yeah it happened
[Music]
the panic factor is the own I'm talking
from sweating Falco so we had your three
more times
oh man sounds wild Carowinds yeah I was
doing alright earlier Smasher is all
uh-oh
I'll use this this downtime so I kind of
refocus right we're reading the wiki
right now we're about to show up
rejuvenated what uh what it is 12:23
what yes already time is flying
holy cow I might be able to like go
through one more time or do we want to
have everyone drop out so that we can
have people who want to fight me once
just fight me one because we are coming
up on the end of the show
indeed indeed I don't know what type of
coordination that would take but I'm
down for whatever these matches are
going by pretty fast true God Isabelle
ooh Daniels on his other main now
he mentioned earlier that he was Isabel
name and up until the day Joker came out
in school it just to let you guys know
the GameSpot house rules are if you ko
Isabel your cop so just a heads up you
don't want to be a cop House Rules we're
hosting it from you yeah exactly
this is the house I will be keeping
track I mean so far so good
we're at Daniel here hey Robin how's it
going welcome I'm sorry that you got
here just learning like the the last
couple of minutes the streaming right
we'll try out that exactly see that's
what I mean mark Isabel is too good and
if you heard us about your cop
exactly that's all there is to it can't
hurt her she's too precious she's just
trying to go fishing like she was waving
at us and you just came down here for a
fight not dare you little pom-pom
I appreciate that she she wasn't just
kind of like a like an alternate or a
villager she's kind of like her own
thing yeah
also she took snakes landmine
canonically her and snigger best friends
and the truth
it's it's so wonderful all right this is
it moment of truth and uh toxic I don't
I don't wanna get me pop I don't want it
to happen the only way to do this is to
to lose her and walk off he's a narc oh
[Music]
the party pop I know she's too cute
she's too cute
oh man whoo Briella
spinnin that bridge is about to
disappear oh oh oh
chased him down that was insane through
the pot off what is happening I love
this
Oh No Oh his nose alone
oh oh this this prohibition I love it
don't those are really fun fight
confirmed glitch is not a cop
[Music]
so cute
[Applause]
so yeah it's it's kind of a weird stage
to kind of get a handle on especially
when it's this new and the version you
were playing on earlier did not the
platform so yeah
all right we might actually have time
just for me to like get back in and do
more and then that that might be where
we call it oh no I think young link is a
cop brew sock I know that you know what
you're doing but you know the rules
everyone needs the walls now see how how
this goes
oh man I can't believe Isabel character
with Ann tenna no match up
all men the projectile game right now
Oh Daniel Daniel oh dang
no we're good we're good Oh to the moon
yeah all right let's go Daniel I love
that that's her her - move so much oh no
cut it out Bruce knock this poor dog
animal of you
ooh okay okay Paul almost gone fishin
nothing coming out that's okay
I'm waiting for his boat just like this
in Warsaw I catch one of the arrow is
like out of the air Busan those a good
fight but I'm sorry your status has been
changed I know
[Music]
dang I'm sorry say I knew there was one
in here am i - no not one more obvious I
think I could at least go until yes for
me a little a little bit a little bit
over but that's fine okay for the love
of banjo yeah for banjo Oh
Ridley Ridley's believe it or not we are
Gigi's Daniel great showing we were able
for you what's still good national oh
dang
ooh I feel like I feel like Dragon
challenge is the thing that links used
to great business like this somehow fits
like it's kanima in a rain even though
it's not straight up we can see it yeah
yeah
Wow nice combo no it's a cute goodness
2d running around our background running
home I can't look at this stage too much
so I'm also trying to take that in tied
it up let's drag him this character he
looks wild yeah really really spend a
long requested character and they
finally made it in no heck yes all right
so this survived this is gonna be the
last fight it's the last fight you guys
thank you for joining our lobby
everybody else in the queue I'm so sorry
but we don't have time but don't worry
if you didn't get a chance to fight or a
chance to fight against who you wanted
to wear this isn't the last time we're
gonna be playing smash so like we said
subscribe to the channel we'll be doing
a whole bunch the the the show that we
normally do it on is on Fridays but this
week is gonna be gears just so many
games to play so many so many things
going on yeah
all right Nick says Govind I'm gonna do
I'm gonna do my best in this stream on a
double yeah yeah hit that dragon with
your bird I'm on it okay
that was a weird I don't know if it
should work yeah good good yeah oh
you're gonna throw me off don't do it
the stage it's okay we can get rid of
him real quick oh oh let's go Ben yeah
no oh don't do it to me what do you get
out of here no Ben I've watched in the
last match and boy watched it
that's okay it's okay it is all good
amazing matches you guys thanks for
hanging out with us thanks for checking
out banjo with us and you know all that
good stuff so is a good time we aren't
here every weekday at 11 a.m. so tune in
tomorrow for somewhere a game spot
live-action but until next time we'll
see you guys later
bye everybody
you